Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Hace ocho meses
decidí que no decidan por mí.
Junto con amigos y amigas
vimos que en todo el mundo
millones de pibes y pibas
se estaban movilizando
para luchar contra la crisis
climática y ecológica.
Y vimos que esto
podía pasar en Argentina.
Así que decidimos organizar la primera
movilización climática del país.
Tuvo lugar un viernes 15 de marzo.
Al principio, no creíamos
que iban a ir muchas personas.
No teníamos muy buenas expectativas
en cuanto a la convocatoria.
Llegado el día nos terminamos encontrando
con 5000 manifestantes
en frente de las puertas del Congreso
y otros miles manifestándose
en distintos puntos del país.
A partir de eso dijimos
"¿Podría Argentina lograr
que se declare su estado de
emergencia climática y ecológica?"
Nos juntamos. De vuelta, nos organizamos.
Y presentamos un proyecto de resolución
frente a la Cámara de Senadores.
El miércoles 17 de julio,
Argentina se convirtió
en el primer país de Latinoamérica
en declarar su estado de emergencia
climática y ecológica.
(Aplausos)
Lo cual igualmente nos marcaba la pauta
de que había
un largo camino por recorrer.
Y gracias a todos estos logros,
se me presentó
la oportunidad de participar
en la primera Cumbre Mundial
de Jóvenes por la Acción Climática,
convocada por Naciones Unidas.
Ahí, junto a la activista Greta Thunberg,
pudimos literalmente
decirle a los líderes mundiales
lo que pensábamos, en la cara.
Y participando de reuniones
con presidentes muy importantes
y empresarios muy influyentes,
me di cuenta de que mi liderazgo
no necesariamente
tiene que estar postergado
a un futuro que no sé cómo va a ser.
Me di cuenta de que
en vez de ser un líder del futuro
puedo ser un guardián del presente.
Hace ocho meses
decidí que no decidan por mí.
¿Qué pasaría si todos Uds.
deciden lo mismo?
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)